Facebook doesn't look like much does it
just a building in Palo Alto but don't
let that fool you Facebook is everywhere
my name is Barack Obama and I'm the guy
who got marked to wear a jacket and tie
in just over six years it went from
college campuses to the White House and
everywhere in between they have amassed
this humongous database of information
about us the goal is to get to ubiquity
I mean Mark Zuckerberg wants everyone to
be on the surface
but not me I've been a rejecter of
Facebook from the beginning
when my son asked me why can't I be on
Facebook why aren't you on Facebook I
started thinking why am I not on
Facebook Facebook is just a website just
a way to connect with friends and family
online right so then why do people
respond so intensely everything in life
only exists if projected out into the
world through Facebook it's like life
itself doesn't have as much meaning
unless it's Amplified and played out in
this social network media
when we first launched we were hoping
for you know maybe 400 500 people
Harvard didn't have a Facebook so that's
the Gap that we were trying to fill and
now we're at 100 000 people so who knows
where we're going next Facebook has
exploded it's more than just social
media into more than just a website
Facebook is a way of life Facebook has
literally changed the world we've moved
uh from the country to the Village to
the town to Facebook it's just getting
started too I think it's just going to
get bigger and bigger and bigger and
even though there are more than a
billion people that use it it's not my
way of life I'm one of those people that
absolutely hates Facebook
but I'm starting to realize my kids are
growing up in a Facebook world and the
scary thing is I have no idea what that
even means and my son never stopped
asking why won't you let me open your
Facebook there better be a good reason
well you're too young for Facebook right
now what that's not fair I have a friend
that's on Facebook but now he's turning
13.
it's legal Facebook age so I have no
choice I need to face why I'm not on
Facebook
[Music]
oh on Facebook
I hate Facebook 10 reasons why we hate
Facebook now I'm not alone on my hatred
of Facebook you know the number one
thing that I hate about Facebook [__]
you Facebook if nothing you can tell me
to make me believe that Facebook is not
from the [__] devil well if you are
frustrated with Facebook tonight you are
not alone I'm not on Facebook I never
will be there's even a Facebook hating
page on Facebook but I'm in the group
that hates and rejects Facebook without
even trying it that's not really me I'd
love to try new things I waited in the
rain for two days to get the first
iPhone I even moved my family to Los
Angeles to pursue a career in an
industry that completely Embraces
Facebook I'm a very social person and I
have all types of friends just not
Facebook friends should I pass this
Prejudice on to my son I need to find
out before he turns 13. is there
something wrong with Facebook or is
there something wrong with me so I
assembled a team of young Facebook
Fanatics to help me research and
document the process now not just
people making a documentary your people
in the documentary
[Music]
there
I just I we need Zuckerberg that's the
point like I need to find out
what he was thinking when he created
this
Masterpiece of disaster
if anybody's gonna show me how to use it
I need him to do it
for customer support
but I'm not available
he's head of entertainment strategy
Global Creative Solutions head of
entertainment strategies Global
Solutions
[Music]
it's not available to record your
message at its own we try every number
around that extension 8400
why 8400 he was born on 84. we are 84.
thank you
Reach Mark and Facebook I'm currently
unavailable please leave your name and
number and I'll get back to you as soon
as possible
uh hello Mark from Facebook I don't know
if you're the mark from Facebook but I
am making a documentary film and at this
point I'm looking for any mark from
Facebook so I'd love an interview
if you can spare some time my number
310.
that's not him right
I think we love that work
at work no other marks he's the only one
dude give me that number
so while I didn't get the mark from
Facebook I did get the creator of
Facebook
and his twin brother you know the twins
from the Facebook movie are you
surprised that it became so big so fast
if it made sense and appealed to the
kids at Harvard University
um then it was going to appeal to kids
at other universities around Mark
Zuckerberg really did sniper you guys
pretty good he was not thinking social
network
um until you guys we yeah there's
there's no question if you look through
sort of the record what he did was
sandbag it to the point where you get
Facebook up first which was our idea and
our website at the time Harvey
connection the concept of connecting
with people and and it's it's brought a
lot of value to my life using Facebook
well so and that exactly that's another
surprise there you use Facebook
absolutely
do you use Facebook yes
you two are on Facebook yeah we are
Facebook users yes we've always been
champions of of what it was and and yeah
social networking didn't didn't wrong us
at the end of the day you guys like
Facebook yes yes you want to show me how
here facebooky thing works all right so
in terms of my profile based on maybe
your interests or where you went to
school it starts zeroing in on people
that it thinks you might be friends with
we've had a unique and pretty funny
experience by being on the site I bet
yes well listen again the irony of
course is that of all the people in the
world
they would have a beef with Facebook
right and that would not be on it it
would be you guys but they were on
Facebook and they made it look pretty
good but not everybody's figured out how
to look good on Facebook here because I
looked at all your Facebook pages and I
wanted to show you the embarrassing
pictures that I found on your Facebook
pages
a bad Facebook page starts with a bad
profile picture
while you might be wondering why would
people post pictures like this on
Facebook I was wondering what might
these people be saying on Facebook
Okay so this open status search you know
you can just type anything in and it'll
search any word that people are using in
Facebook everybody who's posting things
about wheat I got stuff own last night
you know which is crazy like these are
real people's posts so I type in weed
look what comes up look at this one that
party last night was awful crazy wish we
had taped it I danced my ass off and
this one girl completely naked drink my
beer and smoke my weed what I searched
for
I'd marry him in a heartbeat and rape
him if I had the chance
she just posted that tell me what you
think this girl is like
here's a picture of her tag [__]
feelings be a [__]
here's a lovely picture of her fingering
the world
flipping off we don't say we don't say
anything in this country a different
thing in this country here's this here's
his picture her she is flipping off the
world posting that up there I want to
find out what she thinks her Facebook
profile says about her find her send her
a message saying I wanna I wanna I wanna
we'll Skype her or something like that
[Music]
do you see me I can't I see the better
pretty picture of you but not you yet
okay so let's start with your name
my name is Summer Lee if you were a
stranger that didn't know you at all and
just looked at your Facebook page how
would someone describe you they would
look at me like
a lot of fun uh bright
um funny maybe maybe
um I'll go waiting creative summer do
you think your Facebook page is a good
reflection of who you are as a person I
mean when you look at my Facebook page
you're looking at my everyday life
you're looking at the roaming style now
it's possible that I misjudged summer
what I didn't know is that some of her
posts were just song lyrics that party
last night was awfully crazy I wish you
taped it
[Music]
[Applause]
but that doesn't matter because she
posted them on her page and what you
post on your Facebook page
can have real world consequences I would
hope that most high school students
would be very very cautious about the
information they're projecting to the
rest of the world
[Music]
my job for four months out of the year
is to look through thousands of those
applications and try to pick out the
traits and characteristics that seem
like the best match for for what our
college is trying to accomplish I took a
lot of photos off I upped the privacy
settings I know that I probably my
privacy a little higher but it's fine
you wait until after you applied for
college to get the Facebook page yeah
and what about when you go into the job
market do you think there's anything on
your face job market yeah that's where
you gotta like we could you gotta watch
out for your privacy controls and
everything and I've been hearing a lot
about young people who you know they're
posting stuff on Facebook and then
suddenly they go apply for a job for
instance on your form here you've
written your hobbies are voluntary work
and Cinema yes very much so yeah but on
your online profile you've written
getting shit-faced and chasing poontang
I met a restaurant owner who checks
Facebook before he even accepts an
interview he agreed to talk to me if I
concealed his identity and the location
of his restaurant Facebook has
completely changed the way I hire
employees before I interview anybody I
have to see them on Facebook that way I
can see if they're [__] the fat ugly
I can see you know I want something with
big tits nice ass um do you think it's
fair people that you look at them ahead
of time
should be able to make decisions my
restaurant big boobs it's big boobs and
even if you do get the job you can still
get Facebook fired a social studies
teacher suspended tonight for some
comments that he made about same-sex
couples fired for posting anti-muslim
racist statements Ashley Payne taught
English at Appalachian High she says the
pictures just having a beer is that
enough to force someone to resign I put
on Facebook that I have a co-worker
that's a liar a few weeks later Jessica
says she got this termination letter in
the past two years there's just been an
enormous boom in people getting
terminated for this so I could tell my
son how Facebook could cost him a job
but ironically he's far more likely to
get a job because of Facebook
is now the number one job finding and
recruiting site in the world
how do you like that
so how the world sees you on Facebook
depends on what you post on Facebook
[Music]
truck went on my side
all right it's on okay what
literally I just got this email two
seconds ago I have a girl I went to
elementary school with I still kind of
connect with her when we go uh back home
for visits she literally just emailed me
two seconds ago come around you gotta
see this okay
don't forget we have our 20-year high
school reunion
at the end of August does that mean that
I'm not on Facebook so I don't get to go
to my high school reunion for my 10-year
reunion the only invites were on
Facebook that's crazy there's only a
week and a half left in August so it's
either this weekend or next weekend it's
either tomorrow or next weekend if you
weren't invited look at this
Spectrum grad
when is it uh the 27th
next weekend okay so that's next weekend
I think we should we should you gotta go
dude
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
what am I supposed to wear to a reunion
like
it's at the Sticky Wicket in the like in
the maple room
[Music]
yeah is this the maple room with the
reunions like yes
Hi
how are you
now my question is how did you guys find
out about this Facebook right it's like
I didn't know who would be here who
wouldn't be here not that we were trying
to keep it from you yeah not that you're
shooting from me but I'm not on Facebook
don't get invited to me because I'm not
on Facebook you were like the only
person on earth now I apparently you
found out about this through Facebook
figures how did they find out
these people probably are on Facebook
why am I not on Facebook all these
people were on Facebook they already
knew all about each other I was totally
out of the loop
made me feel like some Outsider because
I'm not on Facebook
and do you really even know someone if
you see them on Facebook
there's no Facebook truth police that
picture sucks
this leads some people to create let's
say less than accurate Facebook pages
take the movie Catfish hey Megan Hi how
are you your voice is not at all what I
expected an entire film about this guy
getting duped by a fake Facebook profile
now that sounds fun
if I could create a new version of me
who would I be well I'd be a lot cooler
than I am today yep you are going to be
one incredible guy
all right let's do it
[Music]
what we can do is we can take this
picture this race car driver it's such a
similar pose to this one of Youth and
that is I think very convincing so we
just kinda
put you right in there there we go
[Music]
doing some cliff diving we're gonna
throw you in there you can be right next
to the most interesting man in the world
here let's meet the Playboy Mansion if I
like yeah absolutely this is great
little hang lighting there you are on
Mount Everest oh I'm all over this
all right so so we're live we are live
Steve Steele Steve still exists confirm
Steve Steele is kind of an international
Man of Mystery yeah we checked the
Coliseum at a beach party in Miami
dipton said my dude last night was
seriously out of control what a wild
night those girls we met were straight
Ultra babes oh and thanks for hooking up
the bottle service you the man
what are we doing with Steve Steele now
sending out friend requests yeah and
updating his profile making him seem
like the cool dude that he is Steve
still looks like he's good so how many
friends does Steve Steele have already
31. dude he's only been alive for about
two days 31 friends that's pretty good
friending it's now an actual word in the
dictionary for those who don't know
what it is Facebook is a massively
multiplayer online role-playing game in
which the objective is to collect
friends having a whole mountain of
friends proves that you're worthy that
other people like you that people who
know people who know you have included
you in this or the fold of their larger
group of people in some ways Facebook is
like um it's like a giant bowl of hot
chocolate and all these little people
are bobbing up around like little
marshmallows in your life people have
327 friends I mean how many of these
people are going to come to your funeral
so why are you friending me on Facebook
the pursuit of friends is universal but
Facebook quantifies that Pursuit with a
number a score why are you friending me
on Facebook Facebook
how many Facebook friends do you have
256. you wow you know
six something 600 and something yeah
1700 1700 whereas if I joined it and
just friended you you would
automatically accept me as a friend
I don't know over a thousand you have
over a thousand friends on Facebook
and are these real friends are just sort
of no they're some people don't even
know Facebook says the average user has
139 friends
I wondered if I went on Facebook how
many friends would I have so I have 1230
people in my address book that are my
contacts basically so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to go through them all
and see how many of these would actually
be my friends who I would consider
actual friends and see how that Facebook
number works out Colin Nash yes Melanie
Graham Kurt Durham no there's actually
quite a few people here that I have no
idea who they are I gotta be honest
one
147. the difference is these are people
I've actually met and I'm a real person
on Facebook you don't even need to be a
real person to have friends firm Brad
confirm confirm confirm confirm I just
made like nine friends just now which I
thought is pretty cool
so let's go friends find friends or look
at this
she's not my friend I can now see
everything about her so just found out
my brother is prob fixing to go to jail
hey look her phone number
hello my name's Steve Steele you just
accepted my friend request on Facebook
like five minutes ago
isn't it weird that you have your phone
number out there on your Facebook page
for random people to just call you
tells you where you go to school where
you live all that stuff your email
your birth date how old are you 17.
it's kind of scary
you got a brother is your brother fixing
to go to jail did you just did you post
that
okay I'm gonna do
oh you're gonna
hey
um
would it be okay if I use this in my
film
um
no you don't want me to use your voice
in my film
oh it is kind of creepy isn't I told you
this would be creepy I think we should
reshoot the scene but have you wear a
trench coat with a Mustang oh my God
Julie Cunningham
my friend request firm brag confirm
hey Joseph my name's Steve Katie this is
Steve I'm calling from Los Angeles
California now these people are my
friends a minute ago you just accepted
my friend request how do you know
a stalker
from a fake profile actually I am a
stalker now we're friends on Facebook
but we've never met and you don't know
who I am
but I Know Who You Are
and I'm sitting outside your window
hello
foreign
[Music]
so Steve made a new friend last night
named stouti Stout turns out he's in LA
and he posts his address and phone
number on Facebook so I thought got a
new friend when I come in and sort of
just say hi see him see what's going on
there it is right there
I think that's that's him I recognize
him hello
blue
up knock
all right he wouldn't be stoudy style
would you from Facebook
my name's Steve Steve Steele we're
friends on Facebook hi and your phone
number address is posted on there I
thought I just swing by and say oh you
look like a fun guy all right I had a
few hours I thought before I take off
again all right swing by cool you cool
with that yeah I'm just currently
building stuff but will you show me what
you're building oh okay
um this is a just like little weapons
um holder thing really yeah show up at
someone's house unannounced and they're
making a weapons holder okay
so I'm doing a documentary on Facebook
does it not seem a tiny bit weird that
I've never met you you have no idea who
I am I was able to go on Facebook and
within a few hours I know pretty well
everything about your life where you've
been what you're doing who you're
related to your connection where you
live what you do what you like and like
doesn't that sort of make you go like
maybe not so much on Facebook I should
put out there or insecure about that
stuff I mean if you really look through
my pictures you saw the posts of like my
P jars yes I did yeah like I'm not
really going to be that self-conscious
about anything so if anything I think
it's a testament to how well it works
now we can just boom it is almost like
we're friends now yeah everything locks
all right so it's not like you can come
in and steal tools or anything so I got
a few hours to burn let's have some fun
you got any more beer
[Music]
thanks Daddy sound
good to see you man I'll Facebook you oh
he is exactly like he looks on Facebook
he was totally fun
now we're friends in real life because
we met on Facebook
hard to find fault with that I gotta say
stouti Stout
[Music]
Steve Steele even made celebrity friends
like Roseanne Barr
he hates everyone
Facebook is just all about One
narcissist after another like myself I'm
on there too but I'm not interested in
anybody else's boring life they are not
as interesting as me I think people try
to collect some of my friends on
Facebook because they're basically
narcissists and they have no friends in
real life so
Roseanne what do you think do you think
I should be joining Facebook no actually
interacting with other people will help
sharpen your social skills rather than
dull them further and your skills are
pretty darned
[Music]
I wondered how this would work with a
celebrity if I didn't use Facebook
[Music]
so I watched them go by and then it's
like oh
I think I'd serve I think I saw her I
think that was her this could be it this
could be my chance are you here to pick
her up by chance
[Music]
no
it sucks at least on Facebook you know
exactly where she is you can just reach
out and give her your sign
by using Facebook Steve Steele made
friends with nine Kathy Griffins and now
they can all read posts of Steve's
innermost thoughts
I wonder how that would work without
Facebook you see it is it okay
uh two
it's hard because these are my friends
right here
I knew I mean I I know people so but I
guess on Facebook I would cite them so
France at Kwame in Studio City I hate LA
traffic what do you get for prizes at an
eight-year-old birthday party first me
rice spicy tuna I can eat this all day
can I get a like like for the crispy
rice how cute is this video this isn't
nearly as acceptable as it is on
Facebook and I don't think my friends
would be my friends much longer if I
kept this up this is way easier on
Facebook
but not being someone's friend anymore
Facebook has a solution for that too
and you can see our slogan is unforall
and all for on you know Facebook has
more than 800 million active users each
with an average of 130 friends that's a
hundred four billion Facebook friends
that's 15 times the number of people on
earth
that's too many
it happens to everyone but you never
[Music]
your Facebook being unfriended by
someone close to you can really be
intense
hi hi Mary Lou yeah I am Brad oh hi good
to meet you meet Betty Lou she was
unfriended by her own daughter well I
ended up getting on Facebook
I guess because other people I knew
were on Facebook and they told me about
it and I like to keep track of my kids
and my grandkids are on there if I would
see something that they had written I'd
just answer under comment Facebook was
my main way of keeping in touch with my
daughters one day
uh I was answering something she had
written and I happened to include an
off-color joke I delete posts that are
inappropriate and sometimes I block
people it's not the end of the world
it's just Internet it's just Facebook I
don't hate you or resent you but it's
like being a party crasher awkward do
you think there's other people out there
that say Betty Louie you're an
inappropriate Facebook poster
no one else has told me that no nobody
else has unfriended me okay yeah I felt
like I'm not even part of the family
anymore and I felt so hurt to feel that
her friends meant more to her than her
own mother I'm not sure
what would make my daughter realize
how important Facebook was in my life so
I have to ask what was the joke
well the joke was these two Chinese
people got married and on their wedding
night
when they went to bed her husband said I
think we should have 69 tonight she's oh
broccoli and chicken
Facebook just seems to make
relationships more complicated
my kids are going to grow up in a
Facebook world where online dating has
been reduced to Facebook poking well
this guy Brett from work he poked me
she put them back she wants to Bone you
dude Dan grandma said she poked you and
you haven't sent a poke back
that I didn't even want to do Dan poke
your grandma
it's very likely that all my son's
girlfriends and all my daughter's
boyfriends will begin with Facebook you
see there's a boy you like
no no
[Music]
what's his name no no evidence
Troy shut up Brayden
my wife and I started dating in high
school we didn't have cell phones we
didn't have texts we didn't have email
we had telephones and we had letters
actual written letters I don't know if
you know this I mean I'm sure it's hard
to tell but I kind of like you I know
this comes as a big surprise I mean you
got a great personality good looks
you've got everything it's so weird I'd
do anything for you that's a brief
synopsis of page one and there's one two
three four full pages of the same thing
so I have no idea how this dating thing
works
so I went to my favorite expert
s
fantastic how are you nice to see you so
Grandma what do you know about Facebook
but you know I have to be real honest I
don't know anything about Facebook
and I'm not sure that I want to I don't
want I don't want my name and my
everything out there so let me ask you
though but like when you were dating or
when you were younger if there was
something like Facebook do you think it
would have made a big difference like
how would things be different or not for
me I don't think no because I am a
communicator and I like talking
I like being one-on-one with people you
know what people can do is that before
they go on a date with someone they can
go and check them out on Facebook and
get a little bit how exciting is that
you know all about them before you even
find out about them yeah you know no
that's not the way it should be no it's
not as exciting and not as much fun so
what will my kids be in for dating in a
Facebook world Facebook is one of my
main go-to resources Facebook has
bridged the gap between you know you
don't necessarily have to do online
dating you don't have to be that person
that's doing online dating you're just
on Facebook minding your own business
saying hi to a cute girl what I use
Facebook for is to find women right for
my guys now if I send out too many
random emails to ladies that I don't
know that I'm not already friends with
they'll kick me off Facebook for four
days so I've I had that happen
periodically so this girl that was
sitting next to me I totally recognized
her as one of my Facebook friends
because she was a former Miss California
and so I said oh we're friends on
Facebook she goes you're Gina Hendrix oh
my God I met my fiance because you were
our only mutual friend on Facebook
[Music]
not everybody dating on Facebook is
looking for a fairy tale ending
he's a single guy and he only dates on
Facebook what's your procedure now I
just asked for the Facebook right away
say uh what's your name I'll add you on
Facebook and you take it from there once
I get them to accept me on Facebook I
know I've already got it that shows me
how he operates you don't ask hey what's
your phone number thing anymore no no
phone number is this old news buddy you
go straight to the Facebook oh you're
just gonna start a normal conversation
you're gonna walk in here and I bet you
within five minutes you can
grab a girl's Facebook uh info I'm gonna
get a goose water spicy Crown yeah Goose
water yeah
thank you very much how's your night
going so far good yeah I got you running
the whole bar or what yeah for me this
is busy at all yeah I don't know yeah
it's like you're busy uh hey are you on
uh are you on Facebook by chance uh yes
I am you're all right what uh
you should uh give me your email address
I'll add you to Facebook what do you
think yeah no I'll write it down for you
yeah perfect thanks hon what's your name
Alex Matt nice to meet you Alex
what are you guys up to tonight
casual Monday I came to the right table
then
[Laughter]
well listen we're actually taking off
right away yeah but uh why don't I give
you my email or vice versa and we'll uh
look up on Facebook and we'll take a
minute I am yeah are you guys on
Facebook yeah I figure most people are
yeah
okay well why don't uh actually I'll put
it right in my phone yeah sure just give
me your email nice meeting you girls
yeah take care
she met you yesterday she accepts you
and this is what she sees first the
first thing she's gonna see is my
profile pic this guy's obviously doing
something right he's hanging out with
girls that look like that
say party in Texas [__] really is not a
total stain so let's go and uh check out
some of our pictures here let's see what
she really looks like
not bad not bad
as soon as pick
pictures can be deceiving but kind of a
big ass but
that can be good sometimes too
oh nice tits there for sure
there's a great test actually
okay yeah she's not bad she's a she's a
solid six and a half for sure I'll send
her a message right now
never said I was a [__] scholar but
great
Let's uh
someone to ask if you want to hang out I
like to more kind of just put it out hey
hon
great meeting you pics look great
do you like
question mark when you send a message
like that what are you hoping for the
response to be yeah like a who doesn't
that's a good response oh my God is this
what my daughter has to look forward to
Facebook has had such an effect on
dating that Facebook itself is an
official level of dating it's a term
called Facebook official and now it's
the third highest level a relationship
can be before marriage if your
relationship goes Facebook official
so will your breakup
and a bad breakup on Facebook is really
bad
[Music]
so I could tell my daughter that mixing
dating in Facebook is a bad idea
but just this summer my cousin got
married I was at the wedding
and how did they meet how did this love
affair begin Facebook strangers that met
on Facebook we are officially
Facebook marriage
yeah actually our engagement
from Facebook so Claire went a cut every
single message that we wrote on Facebook
off of a printed sheet and scrapbooked
it I am gonna look really crazy crazy
it's a Facebook mirror it is kind of oh
a lot of Facebook I really hadn't
thought about it at this point
thank you
now that we think about it it's not as
creepy as it sounds isn't it I hope not
and that happens all the time
this couple met on Facebook because they
were both named Kelly Hildebrandt there
are literally thousands of couples that
get married every year because of
Facebook you may kiss the bride once you
have both updated your Facebook profiles
Facebook as a married couple that's just
asking for trouble I've always had this
fear that Facebook would somehow ruin my
marriage
and when you hear the stories and see
how often that happens
I don't think it's that crazy I see
Facebook as a means of cheating in a
small way Facebook can highlight
jealousy and cheating and not being
focused make people discuss what their
boundaries are Facebook makes it really
subtle and really easy to cross
boundaries and cross borders and pretend
that you're actually not doing anything
that your partner wouldn't like the
number of times I hear people coming in
I mean going back to what I have as
clients they come in and say that they
nearly always find out about the
cheating on the internet just look at
the stats on Facebook ending marriages
and I met people that really went
through this hi Angelica yeah hey I'm
Brad nice to meet you hi nice to meet
you I was married for about two and a
half years he was deployed in Iraq and
he sent me a friend request so I added
him we probably dated for about a month
and then I got pregnant I found like
pictures girls would send to him letters
me twice he cheated on me with a 17 year
old girl and then he cheated on me with
this other girl that I thought was my
friend that we were staying with at the
time I think that Facebook definitely
had a lot to do with
me and John were divorcing I think I had
a lot to do with it so I made a fake
profile
you created a fake Facebook profile so
did you just send him a friend request
yes and he accepted it because yeah he
accepted it I sent him messages saying
like straight up like I think you're
cute and he would tell me like on the
Facebook profile saying well I'm married
stuff like that and I'd be like well I
don't care I just want to have sex with
you like pretty much straight up and
then he would say like all right just
don't tell anybody like hold on a second
so what was your response I sent him a
message like he made it back and I was
like yeah this is Angelica like
yeah pretty much you know you just
dropped me off literally probably like
30 minutes an hour ago saying it's okay
we're gonna be together and as soon as I
leave you're on Facebook
trying to have sex with somebody else
that you've never met before in your
life
and so then what was his response once
he was confronted he filed for divorce
for me like all our friends you don't
think I can do about it like he was
telling them like that I was the one
cheating on him and so like just like
totally turning the tables and so yeah
it's like embarrassing and like hurtful
you know like that he could do that to
me it's kind of like I don't mind if he
does it to me I'm saying but it's like
my kid you know like
when he gets older and it's like we're
not together I'm sure my kid will like
wonder why and stuff and it's like what
am I supposed to tell him why you know
like
after all those things like
[Music]
I just don't know
oh dude
she blames Facebook for the demise of
her marriage right which I totally was
on board going in but now you're like oh
my God honey thank God you had Facebook
to catch this guy because if she didn't
catch him red-handed she just would have
kept putting up with it and putting up
with it it's like
it's uh
it's not Facebook's fault that her
marriage failed she married an [__]
how about that
my wife isn't on Facebook either so I
don't know what introducing it into our
marriage would mean they sent me an
email to join it you know I was like
whatever I didn't know anything about it
really and everything I heard was just
girls bitching about other girls
postings and stuff just seems like kind
of going back into high school again no
desire to be on it I don't know
you know my my fiance and I have two
separate Facebook accounts I don't know
her password she doesn't know mine but I
trust that she's being faithful
Facebook is here and social media is
here and it all depends on how you use
it well it's a it's a good question to
know exactly uh what are the boundaries
or what are the rules between a couple
on Facebook and it's the same thing with
every single other thing that you do is
that that is a dialogue so if your wife
and you are discussing and talking about
getting on Facebook
um then you probably are going to have a
healthy attitude to the way you use it
pretty tough if you're talking about a
teenage as a teenager like that people
that you seriously dated before you were
married that they wanted to friend you
yes I would say no that that would not
be that you would not befriending those
people so I should ignore their friend
request no you would say no my wife says
F off
like what happens if all of a sudden
there was like a divorce case and the
lawyers asked to see Facebook records
that is a great question once you open
yourself from real life to Facebook can
you keep anything private the journal's
findings are the latest challenge for
CEO Mark Zuckerberg and his team who
have been criticized in the past for
modifying privacy rules because a bunch
of networking fans are really fed up
with Facebook Facebook is developing
tools that collect users interests
there's some hidden
motive to kind of invade our privacy
take the information and use it to make
money we we never sell your information
advertisers who are using the site never
get access to your information there are
so many issues with the Privacy problems
Facebook has the Facebook privacy
agreement is almost 6 000 words long
that's longer than the US Constitution
Mark Zuckerberg himself had accidental
releases of personal information imagine
that the founder and CEO can't
understand his own site's privacy
settings that's probably because he
didn't read them is it reasonable to
expect that somebody that's 15 or 16
might read a really long essentially
contractual agreement Facebook in
particular
is the most appalling spying machine
that has ever been invented according to
Department of Homeland Security reports
Facebook has replaced almost every other
CIA information gathering program since
it was launched in 2004. it is truly a
dream come true for the CIA much of the
credit belongs to CIA agent Mark
Zuckerberg who runs the day-to-day
Facebook operation for the agency when
people have control over what they share
they're comfortable sharing more when
people share more the world becomes more
open and connected and in a more open
world many of the biggest problems we
Face together will become easier to
solve Mark Zuckerberg grew up with a
generation with no fear of Big Brother
no fear that the government would be
spying on them
this generation wants people watching
privacy is dead
and if you think that's because of
Facebook
you have a deluded sense of how private
your life really is
this is Matt he's 20-something computer
savvy and last week I challenged him to
see how much of my personal information
he could find on the internet without me
being on Facebook
alright so this is why I found the names
of your family members
that's my wife my son my daughter and my
other son yeah cool and you're related
to is that you're like your brother that
is my brother Sean yeah that's my mom
that's my dad okay cool all right that
was my family got it okay family
um this is phone numbers I have
associated with you that is my cell
phone number this is an old house I
don't know if it's your house now or an
old house Road
yep that's my address yeah I own this my
wife bought that yes
these are my Amazon purchases
so is this this is where my kids go to
school I find your driver's license
number d441
[Music]
that is my driver's license number
oh my tax information believe your son's
email that stuff's easy to find your
work history and all that a series of
Home Movies you and your family all on
YouTube this is my birthday that's my
social security number my dad's resume
oh look my mom my credit profile
terrifying what else you got that's it
all this without a single Facebook post
this all started with credit and debit
cards then cell phones email GPS now
even your local grocery store tracks you
just by swiping this card I am giving
them all of my information they know
when I got gas last time now how much
I'm getting now they can tell you where
I've been driving and so now Chevron has
this information I mean do you trust
Chevron I don't know
your entire life is like leaving a
digital trail of breadcrumbs
Google search history can be traced your
text messages if you rent a car have a
mortgage your cable bill the school your
kids go to all stored digitally with
dozens of different companies and
government agencies so does it even
matter if people can read the posts
about your day or see pictures of you on
vacation
another reason to think twice about what
you write on Facebook police in Nashua
New Hampshire say that the social
networking site was used by a ring of
suspected burglars to Target 18 homes in
the month of August meet Mr X
Mr X Rob's houses and now he uses
Facebook to pick his targets
[Music]
potentially so then how would you find
out more information about them
are the Lawless conversations with all
the people which is doing in Houston
with racist throwing wrench is going to
be there yeah it's pretty obvious he's
in California
convertible
of our friends
do you think you're taking a picture of
themselves but all the other stuff
that's in the picture is what really
counters what you get information from
and so how do you end up getting them to
be friends as soon as you greet up
as if one person buys it then everybody
else will buy it essentially we have all
these profiles and you're all
interconnected and then you can collect
information from all of them I
absolutely know that this guy's not home
because he's uploading pictures uh why
is food we have two tags on them
occasion okay so if it's always even
worth it I need to see what kind of
stuff he does yeah he's not a nice watch
has nice jewelry arms
[Music]
looks like
teams
basically is
how do you know that the house doesn't
have an alarm all you need is the
properties
like what kind of tools would you use to
get past an alarm
[Music]
in the world
and it's not just existing criminals
using Facebook Facebook is turning
people into criminals two men arrested
during the Mayhem will pay a high price
for their crimes they were sentenced to
four years each in prison for using
Facebook to incite some of the disorders
the police are now using Facebook to
solve crimes they can subpoena your
Facebook page but most of the times they
don't need to that's because the
criminals themselves are posting about
their crimes on Facebook
Facebook make them stupid are these just
stupid people on Facebook
[Music]
during the Vancouver riots after the
Canucks lost the Stanley Cup
the police used Facebook to make
hundreds of arrests
these idiots were posting themselves all
over Facebook look at all the cameras
[Music]
how dumb are these people a lot of
people were coming down because they
were seeing these posts on Facebook they
were seeing sort of the Carnage they
were seeing sort of the chaos that was
sort of the Catalyst for people to to
get down there
[Music]
in 10 minutes I would expect a rush of
people
[Music]
one guy became the star of the entire
Riot Brock Anton
he posted on Facebook that he punched a
cop well that post got picked up by
every major reporting agency in North
America the internet lit up
[Music]
permit so he's either gonna
like his name or like live with this
forever
I mean how do you apply for a job if
this is what's out there
once this stuff hits the web your
stupidity is there forever you can see
his daughter taped at the wrists ankles
and mouth but even scarier the father's
caption this is what happens when my
baby hits me back it shows several young
men in the desert carrying guns and
holding up a t-shirt with President
Obama's likeness on it that appears
ridden with bullet holes gossip used to
be just gossip very unreliable and more
importantly completely deniable I did
not have sexual relations with that
woman
the model my brother and I grew up with
was deny till you die not so easy when
evidence is plastered across the web
with picks and videos and posts and
updates around every corner he just
can't get away with what he used to this
is a whole new problem for kids well
being kids now everything they do and
everywhere they go someone can see them
two on their left
Sarah
[Music]
well when you want to post something new
anything you post online anyone can see
now Facebook doesn't cause teens to do
stupid asinine things
it just makes a more permanent Mark when
they do
[Music]
oh man
as old school dude it's old school that
is a police exhibit
article number two
1990. that's intense man wow Brent and I
we had a ran with a pretty tough crowd
uh did some crazy stuff
uh but yeah it was a different time no
there was no cell phone cameras and
Facebooks and uploading to the internet
and
just didn't have to worry about that
kind of stuff why am I not on Facebook
um honestly because I think as soon as I
signed up on Facebook
Chuck Norris would come out of the
bushes roundhouse me in the face and say
Sean what were you thinking real men
aren't on Facebook if Facebook was
around when my brother and I were
teenagers life would have turned out
much different
as a father of three little ones this
terrifies me how will I be able to keep
their mistakes off Facebook to keep
their dumb moments from being
permanently etched in internet history
my six-year-old is so proficient on the
computer his world revolves around it
and my oldest son is already texting and
chatting online with his friends
Facebook is coming from my son and
there's nothing I can do to stop it
how do parents deal with teens on
Facebook remember summer I asked her mom
do you monitor Summer's Facebook page
deliver privacy you know if she's a
teenager but at the same time I know
that
I can't post anything on there about
anything she posts or else she'll
Delight me well that's one parenting
style there are others that right there
is your laptop this right here
is my 45.
[Applause]
your mom told me to be sure I put one
there for her so that one's from her
children are on some device some media
device they're plugged in way too many
hours in the day children don't realize
that when they put things out there on
Facebook or social media it's there to
stay parents need to learn what Facebook
is so there's no way I can just tell my
kids you're not allowed to go on
Facebook
oh almost every teenager in this country
is on Facebook well 97 of the teens we
pulled are actually on Facebook so
they're all there what is it about
Facebook that is so addictive for
teenagers well the kids don't see it as
a site they see it as life and it's
where everybody they want to know and
everybody who knows them and everybody
who is everybody is meet Cheyenne she
says she's completely addicted to
Facebook she's 18 years old when I wake
up I have the phone next to me
and I'm checking Facebook
right now yeah yeah I'm on it more than
12 hours a day
um
an hour
do people get distracted when they talk
to you and you're on your phone yeah
they're like
um hello she checked her Facebook 43
times while I was trying to do this
interview
in your life it takes up that much time
and energy no it's like my best friend
well I have a best friend but it's like
my real I don't know how to explain it
it's weird
but yeah
I check
I pay attention more to Facebook than
anybody else
anything else
wow okay can I see from for one second
so now what if you don't check Facebook
how do you have a conversation with
someone
I don't
when I finally took her phone she could
barely speak
um
[Music]
I just want to check like one message
did you want it back yeah
I wasn't surprised how addicted she was
to Facebook as much as I was appalled
how little she could communicate without
it
could Facebook do this to my son totally
addicted to that short form
communication can't even talk in full
sentences anymore it's crazy when you
left for a few minutes I talked to her
are they guys or girls or
you have groupies
London from Facebook
so you get a little you get a little
Fame I mean honestly and if you're
really honest with me that's the draw
right yeah this was sort of a
breakthrough it wasn't Facebook that was
addictive it was the feeling that
Facebook was giving her
Facebook made her feel famous
in her Facebook world she was a star
this is Kitty they call her the pink
lady of Hollywood
[Music]
wow you weren't kidding it really is
Kissy Kissy poo
kissy I am a character actress but I'm
not really that famous yet but I'm a
reality TV personality for 28 years I've
been the pink lady of Hollywood then I'm
branding it and I'm trademarking it wow
so having a bit of an obsessive
personality which is perfect so tell me
how Facebook has sort of played into
that for you everything I do I put on
there I always have it on my library my
crackberry I do pictures a lot because
people love photos photos is the thing I
usually get a ton of license right oh
thank God everybody likes me and it's so
funny because in school it was not
popular at all like I was a dork but now
I'm like super popular I have you know
thousands of friends can you show me
your Facebook page and what you do yeah
well uh do I have to show you yeah of
course okay always exaggerate so I don't
have as many friends as I said I did
I'm so bad 836
that's still an awful lot
I don't know why I'm not getting more I
need to get more immediately if not
sooner so friend me on Facebook right
now out of this list how many people do
you actually know maybe 50.
you could only pick one the fortune or
the fame what would it be probably the
same because the fame is more fun
everybody wants approval everybody wants
to be loved that's what Facebook does it
makes people
feel good
bottom line
it makes kissy feel good good kissy
hello
but you know what like thank God for
Facebook she has a little bit of her
dream Facebook gives her that dream what
she wants more than anything is to have
a little bit of Fame and to be relevant
and Facebook gives that to her where
would you get that 10 years ago nowhere
with Facebook anyone Can Feel the Rush
of Fame a feeling of importance
for Facebook a nerdy shy kid went home
to nobody and nothing now he goes home
and he can interact be funny have
friends and get positive feedback
[Music]
okay but what about the cool kids do you
think James Dean would have been on
Facebook what about John Wayne I don't
think so how about Wayne Gretzky
he is on Facebook
and what about Chuck Norris
he's on Facebook too
although I don't think Chuck Norris
joined Facebook I think Facebook joined
Chuck Norris
[Music]
do your Facebook account would you
confirm his friend request or just
delete it out
Jesus have been on Facebook would Jesus
have been on Facebook
it's a good question
you know it's very possible Jesus Jesus
used methods that were available to him
at the time to spread his message
um because it's possible turns out Jesus
is on Facebook which makes sense because
in the right hands Facebook can perform
Miracles you know if you lost touch with
somebody it used to take a bit of
detective work to find them again well
now the internet has made that a lot
easier a father and daughter are
celebrating together tonight after
spending years searching for each other
I'm the happiest man in the world I just
had a vital organ taken out of me Ali
donated her kidney to a man she met just
five months ago on
stranger who needed help his name was
Dan Garrett and the page read simply my
husband needs a new kidney there are
hundreds of thousands of jobs and
billions of dollars in revenue flowing
into our country because of Facebook and
it really does help people keep up their
relationships and share important
moments I felt this when my cousin came
to visit she had got leukemia when she
was 21 and now has had three bone marrow
transplants been near death more times
than you can count we haven't connected
more than a couple of times in the last
15 years would that be different if I
was on Facebook
there are thousands of Facebook users
that have died with their Facebook
profiles live on
my close friend Denise cramsey who
produced Extreme Makeover home Edition
died suddenly and tragically her
Facebook page is still active
that's her
pictures of her and stuff you can see
that I don't have any of these pictures
of her I never seen any of these
pictures
I didn't even know she had a Facebook
page
and that got me thinking about the other
relationships in my life and the ones
that I was missing out on
oh my God
[Music]
said
oh my God that's him
this is my old best friend from high
school literally one of my favorite
people in the world it's been 20 years
haven't seen or heard from him totally
lost touch it's
still able to find him in literally 30
seconds
now I can message him how do I do that
so what's going on Brandt doesn't know
that every time he logs into his
Facebook is Steve Steele that everybody
can see it
so is he logged in right now yes he is
yes
okay I have to admit it
I had been spending a lot of time as
Steve Steele on Facebook
and I was really enjoying it but I had
started posting my real life pictures
and Steve steals Facebook friends
they were starting to be my real friends
the truth is
it was getting hard to tell how much of
this was Steve Steele
and how much of this was me
[Music]
say nothing good comes on Facebook
and really it is not anything about
Facebook the biggest thing I found was
is that what made Facebook so popular
and I figured out what it is now I
ramble on here a little so let me sum it
up
what makes Facebook so unique
is that it's able to marry two of the
most powerful human emotions
narcissism and insecurity
first Facebook allows you to create a
world that centers around you
then it lets you protect that World by
surrounding it with only people you
accept as friends
it's like controlling the guest list to
an exclusive party where you are the
star
Facebook allows you to feel important
and safe at the same time
kind of Genius that is why Facebook
works
make sense yes
what did you say exactly
you said
there's either something wrong with
Facebook or there's something wrong with
me and now you're telling me
there's nothing wrong with Facebook
I'm not going to say there's nothing
wrong with Facebook
but after everything we've seen I would
have to agree that the problem is not
Facebook itself so where does that leave
[Music]
Dr Drew Pinsky has an online narcissism
test consistently celebrities prove to
be the most narcissistic and insecure
people and the highest tested celebrity
score of 34 was from the Howard Stern
shows Robin Quivers you discovered in
your research was that Robin was not
only the biggest narcissist on our show
the biggest narcissist that you found in
anything get out of here yeah
she was the worst case of any narcissism
you'd ever seen I believe that about
worst case but she is the winner
are you ready
I have a natural talent for influencing
people I am not good at influencing
people I'm an actual town I am not sure
if I would make a good leader I see
myself as a good leader Jesus I am much
like everybody else I am an
extraordinary person who would say they
are like everybody else just I answered
like normal person right
35 wow
maximum is 40. the average for American
is 15.
what are you laughing at you mean too
narcissistic for Facebook
I mean that's possible
what does this mean I had to find out so
I went to the source there he is hey
it's pleasure so good doctor yes sir I
one thing I really want to ask you one
of the strange things that's happened in
the world today is this Facebook
phenomenon Facebook has come on it feels
like simultaneously with the
availability of camera phones everything
in life gets documented and not only
does it get documented it only exists if
I project it out into the world through
Facebook or email or some other Twitter
some other means so it's almost like
life itself doesn't have as much meeting
unless it's Amplified and played out in
this social network media is Facebook
addictive do you find there's something
called process addiction if you're
feeling angst or unpleasant or low
self-esteem or life is not worthwhile
you can get lost in this world and
really sort of float away into a dream
world and be disconnected from your
feelings and how do you think narcissism
and Facebook sort of well they do kind
of go together in the sense that if
dissociation is a common mechanism
dissociation is something that comes on
and people have had severe narcissistic
injuries and may have narcissistic
process and obviously what I mentioned
already you know sort of needing to
project yourself out of the world is a
pretty nice statistic impulse like my
real self doesn't really exist unless I
project this thing out are you on
Facebook
I am but I don't I rarely go there I'm
time to tell people what I'm doing all
day I'm not gonna do that it sounds so
good when you say it you know what I
mean so um one of the things I wanted to
ask you about and um
that I brought here today which was a
little shocking to me is I went and I
took your narcissism test yep I was a
little surprised that the answer seemed
so obvious to me so you did you didn't
adulterate it in any way no this was a
hundred percent I mean Jake was there
honestly it was an honest assessment and
uh that was my score 35 yeah
in the Robin Quivers range yeah that's
higher which well it's very high it
means at least you are
steeped in narcissistic defense
strategies and that you probably had
some narcissistic injuries growing up
and so narcissistic injuries right um
abandonment neglect abuse things like
that that sort of leave you
um distrusting other people having
difficulty in relationships and intimacy
that's usually I don't know you so I
don't know if that's true or not and so
Facebook maybe was a scary place where
um maybe these things about yourself
would be challenged
maybe you'd find other people
that don't reinforce all this
oh but it doesn't mean that I think I'm
so great it actually means I don't feel
inside I feel kind of empty and I may
not regulate my emotions very well and I
need these things to keep me buttressed
to keep me pumped up so I'm not exposed
to those underlying feelings that aren't
so nice
and maybe those underlying feelings are
what might have been exposed on Facebook
oh
wow Mommy
[Music]
quiet
why are you it has been drunk
what does this mean
I didn't know what to think of all this
until it hit me I wasn't scared of
Facebook I was scared of who I would be
on Facebook and the thought of what
Facebook could bring out of me
that's why I've been pushing it away
it turns out I actually love Facebook
just my own version of it my life is a
safe protected and totally controllable
social network
this was more about my need for control
and my issues than it ever was about
Facebook
I'm narcissistic and insecure
I'm not on Facebook
because I am Facebook
my instinct as a parent is to protect my
son from anything that can cause him
harm
but at some point I have to realize he's
growing up
[Music]
I just don't think there's any way to
stop stop hitting on you know be like if
we were kids and you're like oh you
can't have a bike it's like what are we
gonna be the parents they're like no you
can't be on Facebook
you know
I think that's not gonna work yeah
okay less
hey buddy what are you doing
can we come in
yes I want to talk to you about Facebook
[Music]
I was thinking that when you turned 13
you can uh dude
put your phone down
my name is Kayla spinvitic and
I don't have a job
what would you do if you could get on
Facebook
let's see
I had
a thing like posting your life like
click tuna salad greatest thing ever I
don't understand that I'd probably post
things that people would actually like
to see like comedy
or something like that like like there's
like an open space in like the giant
mall like or there's just based on like
is that is that a spot and then it turns
out it's just a really [__] car like
Jared that was a big I thought it would
be a free space all right so that's
funny
it yeah but now when I say it it's funny
with pictures
[Laughter]
oh here here comes the fun part
I don't think you're on Facebook
because you because everybody has
already gone on it
and you don't want to be that one person
who's like well since everybody else is
on Facebook I guess I kind of have to to
fit in but you don't want to fit in you
want to be the different person the
problem is not the problem it's your
attitude about the problem
Captain Jack Sparrow I remembered
another quote okay go ahead all right
and Optimus sees the donut
uh I forgot what the other name was
seize the whole
the donut has a hole in it the good an
Optimus sees the donut a pessimist sees
the whole
yeah that I got it so for you it would
be you see all the good things like
people like The Optimist will see all
the good things about it for the persons
to see the bad thing about people's live
being ruins but really it's not their
fault I mean it's not Facebook's fault
it's their fault
and am I The Optimist or the pessimist
here kind of neutral you see the donut
but you also see the hole and wonder why
would they put a hole in a donut
no he's right
while I still had a couple of months to
decide about Kayla's and Facebook it was
time to decide about me and Facebook
[Applause]
ready
you know I still have no idea what
you're gonna do I sort of don't either
but today is the day
I've got it ready
the question is do I close the book on
Facebook forever
or do I sign up
and join and embrace it
you ready I'm ready are you I am
here it is
that's awesome
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah it's kept in between as we sit in
silence Blakely staring at our screams
[Music]
where everyone believes
you've got the perfect life
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't know you but I really like your
Facebook page
and I've clicked through all your
pictures and I've seen your
holidays
and I know you're still single and
you're looking for a guy
thank you
hey stop sign is Aquarius
so is mine
cause it's such a waste your Facebook
page ain't you
here's the Mary you choose to take that
picture that ain't true
it's your Facebook page
yeah it's your Facebook page
you like your mirror and you really like
the Rolling Stones
[Music]
of all the pictures you have you never
really alone must be lonely yeah cause
it's such a waste your Facebook page in
you
[Music]
it's a marriage
sick that pictures that ain't true
it's your Facebook page
thank you
should attack you in a photograph
cause you know I was feeling sad
should have liked your profile pic
then you see I'm stuck in your Facebook
page
Facebook page
[Music]